you can't put calories on a leaf you
can't put calories on spinach you can't
do this you just eat it goes from the
ground that's when I think with all this
calorie counting and stuff like that how
do you actually calorie count a carrot
because each carrot is different or each
other
and also did you know calories
you know food calories when they say
you're on the label like whatever
calories it is did you know each person
consumed in their body when they consume
food the calories change and it's
different for each person it then boils
down to your metabolism yeah yeah but
you can do a metabolism like my whole
point is this is how we can all fit like
this is something that can be fair it
can be changed and then and that's the
great thing about like women most of the
things that men want can be fixed like
men want fit feminine friendly women
those are all things that can be fixed